let us discuss the rent pocalypse yeah
Brent pocalypse so we had talked for a
bit about how people weren't gonna pay
rent
people don't have money to pay rent and
when that happens the next wave of
economic destruction would be upon us
because while a lot of these lefties
don't understand that there's a lot of
work that goes into maintaining property
they these companies have staff they
have employees they have groundskeepers
electricians maintenance whatever yep
now those people all gonna get paid but
the story from The Wall Street Journal
is that nearly 1/3 of US apartment
renters didn't pay April rent some
tenants will be temporarily protected
from eviction by a patchwork of federal
and local laws but my understanding has
only last for about three months yeah
and what do you think what do things
gonna happen when so there was this big
story BuzzFeed covered it where a
building sent out an email to everybody
saying hey you like here's what you can
do if you need benefits just so you know
rent is still due we won't evict you
because of the law but you can be
evicted later right and so the company
forgot they accidentally cc'd everybody
on it I guess oh they weren't supposed
to I mean maybe they didn't care but now
everyone had access to everyone else's
email and so they've organized a rent
strike on the entire company oh geez
and the reason that's messed up is why
tired well if you do that you slap in
the face of your lint you slap your
lather in the face nothing's gonna
happen in three months do you think
they're gonna be like well now that this
is all over keep paying your rent we're
all good or do you think they're gonna
be like get out I mean they're gonna get
high they're gonna tell them to get out
it's not surprising I'd be willing to
bet if if you had an email from your
landlord and you emailed back saying I
lost my job as me of the month I hope
you understand something I can do they'd
be like we'll figure something out yeah
I mean that's basically what the email
said right if you need help well here's
the way to get some help sad but you
gotta pay rent
you still got to pay a rancher and we
can't evict you now but we can't evict
you later and we will yeah it's not
really a surprise its it's not
surprising take this out so the Wall
Street Journal writes nearly 1/3 of US
apartment renters didn't pay any of
their April rent during the first week
of the month according to new data to be
released Wednesday by the National meet
a multi-family housing housing
and a consortium of real estate data
providers the numbers are the first hard
look at how many Americans are
struggling to make rent during the krona
virus pandemic the data come in the
first of the data comes in the first of
weekly reports on unpaid rent from nm HC
a landlord trade group but I got a stop
real quick because why are we assuming
it was all people unable to pay right
how many of them were alive ooh now's my
chance
yeah exactly how do we know we just we
saw the BuzzFeed where they were like we
refused to pay
I blame Cheesecake Factory yeah stood it
out yeah we're not gonna pay come April
first well it what why are you even
announcing them they said they couldn't
pay okay
and now now what's what's AMC my quite a
business yeah what do you know what do
you do all those all that property at
all these all these malls it's gonna
this is what I've been saying for a long
time the housing market is gonna turn it
that they're gonna use it if they're
gonna become homes they have big cute
like movies no no well and malls
you said malls and yeah movie theaters
maybe but think about what Amala
yeah yeah it's got all these like stores
with like nice and lit up Sun roofs
throughout the whole middle so it's like
Gardens in the middle and then people
it's gonna be apartments it doesn't make
sense for everyone goes online
- yeah malls are collapse to get
everything yeah exactly
small-time businesses are just they're
getting shut down especially now like
half of them are gonna go under this
it's it's it's it's interesting cuz I've
actually been to a dying mall this was
during Ferguson yeah there was a there
was like two towns over to the west of
Ferguson was a mall that had I think
like 90 empty storefronts Wow and it was
it was partly because of the rioting in
Ferguson okay so when like one of the
first one the first rioting broke out
the they locked the whole place down
with like police because they were
worried about looting and stuff and
people naturally got freaked out and
didn't to show up what ends up happening
that is you have a lot of these stores
that operate at a loss because these
these big companies I don't know I don't
know if there's any specific I can
specifically to name but you know I'll
give you a Starbucks example Starbucks
will make a ton of money in one location
of a city and they'll make they'll be
losing money in another look
but they want the marketing in the
presence right so the the successful
store subsidizes the weaker stores as it
happens in malls you'll end up with you
know lids or something and they
Starbucks and GameStop's and and they
know that this one mall what else isn't
that lucrative but they want the brand
recognition of the people who come and
go yeah
so when one store leaves then there's
less incentive for other for people to
go there even and then for other
businesses to even set up because the
benefit of the mall is that there's foot
traffic yeah
so if high-profile stores start leaving
for any reason they don't pay their rent
AMC for instance if AMC goes out of
business these movie theatres or even
Cheesecake Factory yeah how many people
have been like oh let's go to Cheesecake
Factory where is it at the mall hey
great we'll go we'll put our names in
wait 15-20 minutes walk around the mall
and buy stuff now that Cheesecake
Factory is gone people are gonna be like
let's go somewhere else
now the mall is gonna it's this this is
the cascade that destroys the mall and
that's why it's not just about you know
rent for four people and where they live
because this is the story specifically
talking about apartment rentals yeah
true but businesses yeah exactly all
rent
yeah it's impacting across the board for
sure but then you have these activists
which is the Wall Street Journal
actually shows I wonder what if they're
trying to make this you know what is
this they say protesters in Los Angeles
says last week called for rent
forgiveness due to the surge in
coronavirus related job losses
why not cellphone forgiveness yeah rent
forgiveness so like they don't have to
actually pay for it like oh we get this
month free is that what they're looking
for what about cable TV forgiveness
what's the difference between look I get
it you need a place to live you can't be
homeless yeah food and show but you're
you're paying for some kind of service
or product or something you're paying to
use the space yeah why should we forgive
this and nothing else this is one of the
biggest problems with a lot of these
lefty activists like especially the
minimum wage increases it's like why $15
why not 21 at 25 why not 30 yeah and
then you actually had I think receded to
laid said okay then we'll do 20 and
after they got you know they vote on 15
and she then said 20 and then she kept
it just keeps going up but never ends
yeah so well I'm curious as to what the
economic impact is gonna be of you know
all this the walther Journal says that
only 69 percent of tenants paid any of
their rent between April 1st and the 5th
compared with 81 in the first week of
March and 82 in April 2019 the count
includes renters who only made include
renters who only make partial payments
many renters who haven't yet paid may
still pay later this month wow that's
that's actually really interesting
that's not that much of a difference
right
if only 82% paid their rent in April
last year yeah there was no pandemic
last year so that's not that big of a
drop
it's a 13% different it's not like you
know going in it's like Oh a hundred
people one hundred percent of people pay
the rent you know eventually maybe not
like right on time but they pay the rent
and that's clearly not true only eighty
two percent paid last year Wow yes it's
an interesting number the water Journal
reports the federal government has
agreed to let apartment building owners
with government-backed mortgages defer
their mortgage payments and the Federal
Reserve also said it would buy up bonds
tied to certain multifamily loans those
measures however only cover part of the
total rental market and don't address
loans held by banks without a
governmental guarantee less than
one-third of US rental units are
federally financed and covered by
protections in last month's stimulus
package according to an estimate from
the Urban Institute a washington-based
think tank that's not a lot no you know
what I think it really is men I think
there's a decent amount of people who
are like now's my chance
I'm not gonna pay rent yep and they're
there justifying it and look you have
purchased in Los Angeles rent
forgiveness these people know to talk no
idea what they're talking about they're
basically just demanding something for
free feels like it yeah I I get it you
know we don't people to be homeless but
you're able-bodied
and like these people aren't these these
producers look young like you can get a
job man
yeah it's one of the biggest problems
with a participation trophy era is that
none of these people want to work at
McDonald's I worked at a fast food
restaurant was my first job I didn't
care there's a job mine was blockbuster
Blockbuster Video I worked a blog post
and what's and and and and so what's
what's the big deal how much they pay
they pay minimum wage I don't even
remember it was years ago yeah I'm sure
they didn't pay you 18 or so I'm sure
they paid you the bare minimum
yeah definitely there's so many young
people or younger people today that
they're like
I'm not gonna work McDonald's okay then
you'll be broke yeah but that what they
do is they demand free rent or free
product or government pay for things
mm-hmm you know it's it's it's kind of
strange to me cuz I was watching some I
was watching the history of like the
burger the fast-food burger in America
okay and it was like there was appeared
in this country where it wasn't
demeaning to work low-skilled jobs it
was like people were like I got a job
what do you do I'm part of a you know
food prep line it's like oh cool
no and you just flip burgers and then
something happened where we start
getting snootier and snootier yeah good
point I remember growing up and and you
know people would say to me like you
don't want to end up flipping burgers do
you and I'm like like will I be happy
right it's like yeah oh well then what's
the big deal yep that's what my daddy
say he's like what do you wanna be when
you grow up and then I was like wrong
answer happy yeah that's all that
matters I like that yeah I remember I
was uh I was riding with my dad I was a
little kid I saw a homeless guy riding a
bike okay presumably homeless like
carrying her stuff around and I said I
was like a little kid I said that's sad
and he's like what's sad and I was like
oh the homeless guy and he goes why is
that said he could be the happiest guy
in the world for all you know and I was
like and the guy didn't look sad
it's good peanut active right there yeah
so you know the funny thing is about
these people who feel like they're above
everything like they deserve free rent
because you know housing is a human
right or whatever it's like why should
why should the immigrants who come this
country you know they work fast food why
should they have to do that and not get
free rent but you think you're deserving
of the free run I mean you encourage
them to come here and stay there and
then and then what they have to wash
your dishes and then you get to live for
free how does that make sense
it doesn't know it doesn't know the
other thing too is like what if you were
really good at flipping burgers yeah
right yeah so I'll tell you my all right
we will wrap up on this one final
thought some business advice for
everybody I may have said this on the
show I don't know if I did but let me
let me ask you guys a question
did I ever well I'll just ask you anyway
Adam if you got a call right now from
McDonald's and they said Adam Craig ler
and you were like yeah that's me they'd
be like we want you to work the cashier
at our downtown Philly location starting
tomorrow 10:00 a.m. what do you say
how much boom how much you paying me
exactly right answer right cuz I know I
love my job right now right I get to
talk to these awesome people on you you
to you this is great but you know most
you know most people say what no no I
can't be seen it McDonald's so so people
often ask me like how do you be
successful in all that and I asked him
this question if McDonald's called you
right now and said we want you to work
the cashier mm-hmm what would you say
they're like no I'm like why would you
say no because I don't want to do that
I'm like it's the wrong answer the right
answer is how much you're like what if
they paid you twenty thousand dollars
per day a day you know all right maybe I
could work that register and so good
this is what people how people you know
end up being bad at business true it's
like you don't even know what they're
gonna offer you you don't even know how
long it's gonna be for mm-hmm and
they're like well I just assumed boom
there it is you assumed got a no you get
asked yeah you go do the research so
here's what I tell people you know what
when I used to get when I get hit for
our jobs they're like would you be
willing to do this I say I don't know
give me $1,000 and when they're like
whoa $1,000 that's too much money I'll
be like okay I didn't want to do it
anyway yeah you know so it's like
whatever but at least now I know yeah or
or they might be like okay a thousand
bucks and you're like wow really a
thousand bucks maybe I should answer
yeah so yeah right exactly I had a
friend who got a job offer that was it
paid too little and they were like I'm
gonna say no I don't think I'm gonna
take it and I was like why do I say no
well I was like would you do the job for
ninety thousand a year and they're like
nah and I was like how about 120 and
they went well 120 yeah I'm like there
you go send the email yeah say it's what
you want and then they're like what
they're not gonna offer it to me and I'm
like congratulations then you don't get
a job you didn't want in the first place
some and sure enough it sent an email
and the company mailed back that's too
much we appreciate it have a nice day
yeah that's what you were gonna say no
yeah exactly I even bother but imagine
if they said yes right anyway to wrap
this back up I think we have a problem
with weird urban elitism and I wonder if
like these people saying rent
forgiveness can we like put him on a
farm like I mean like - like going on a
retreat not like what was going to find
us a reference
wasn't it I don't know disciplinary camp
yeah it was a reference to something
specific about telling people to a farm
no I mean like quite literally like
showing them how to how to grow food and
how to do basic stuff yeah yeah
not by force that was I was just
thinking like man the farmers are gonna
be like get these people out of here
yeah it's funny though these come on
he's peed on how to work these I gotta
work on a farm Oh totally serious work
but think about these activists how
they're like all about immigrants and
illegal immigrants yeah it's like you
want to be what you want you wanna be
really honest illegal immigrants work so
much harder than these people who really
do it was funny like I can Trevor who
tweeted this they were like well look we
will gladly exchange the Socialists for
the illegal undocumented workers who
work really hard yeah like we're good so
you hey it's your call
yeah cuz all those people know what it's
like to have nothing right they they had
no comfortable buh-buh ever they see
Americans in their comfortable bubble
and they're go I will do anything to
have that yeah and I may do and then you
have some overweight people demanding to
get free rent yeah it's like I know
people who would like scrapes come off
of the floor with a toothbrush for a
minimum wage in this country because
it's so much like you know made in this
country is a lot of money relative to a
lot of other places very true and there
are people who are like wow I would get
to do that make all this money it's
amazing yeah yeah do you think it's
because of higher education because I'm
wondering if the bars and B being
artificially set high I think it's I
think it's partly yeah I think it's
these people are being told by their
parents that they're gonna be the
president right you know well the same
parents who are telling them that they
can do whatever they want are also
telling them that they have to go to
college yep some wondering if there's
overlap you can do anything but go get
in debt yeah get in debt first yeah
that'll work
that's smart yeah I think it's really
funny when I see people I know who have
ridiculous debt like hundreds of
thousands in debt yeah and they're
trying to advocate advocate for why the
government should forgive all of it and
I'm like isn't it strange that the
people who think it's the right thing to
do are the ones who are saddled with
debt and the people who don't have the
debt think it's the wrong thing to do
it's almost like you dug yourself into a
hole made mistakes and then we're alike
somebody else should pay for it debt
forgiveness now holding up the sign
that's the same thing
yeah rent forgiveness you know you know
cities are gonna collapse this can't
continue the cost of rent goes up the
value of labor it goes down and then how
do you maintain these buildings they
like I mean look at San Francisco the
place is a nightmare it really is it's
like poop everywhere they have a poop
department like like firefighters have
been cracking up when you told me that
it's a real thing what did you laughing
at the misfortune of dystopian nightmare
think about what San Fran is too it's
like I mean what this is it this is an
LA these these rent forgiveness people
you know what man if somebody builds
something mm-hmm and they use their
labor you know and they work really hard
for it why do these people think they
deserve it for free
just you know what maybe they don't
think they deserve it maybe they just
they found an easy out yeah put on a
mask put on gloves threaten people and
later for free I can't pay rent or I can
I just everyone else isn't doing it so
I'm gonna I'm gonna just go full in and
make signs and just you know be an
activist against this just because I
don't want to pay rent yeah you know why
not why not go all the way
why twice why stop at like I shouldn't
have to pay rent how about the
government should give me personally a
million bucks oh let's go let's go all
the way I should be king of the planet
everyone give me everything it's
interesting because if you're asking for
free stuff because you think you deserve
it and look I think there's an argument
he made about fighting for certain
rights but arguing that you have a right
to someone else's property which is
supported and maintained by their labor
and you shouldn't contribute to it it's
a really weird thing but why stop there
yeah that's true
why not how about the difference how
about we own the building why rent yeah
yeah exactly I'm hiring for the moon man
is if you miss you'll hit the stars are
in for the stars what is saying shoot
shoot for the moon because if you miss
you'll land among the stars there you go
what that rent forgiveness sign down but
that's like that's like actually
flinging yourself into the moon yeah
sounds dangerous why not just hold up a
sign saying give me ownership of the
building yeah yeah why stop there give
me the owner and make me mayor yeah
Supreme Chancellor of the city why even
stop there yeah but in more in a more
serious nature
why literally stop with only rent why
don't they demand for utilities free
utilities 3/3 access free maintenance
yeah the people who built this should be
forced to maintain the building for free
I'm not gonna give anything it's like
well I'll keep paying Con Ed cuz I want
my electricity is down cuz they'll shut
it off but I want rent free yeah it's
like well there's a lot of people that
are just like you know my grandfather
was one of those he had like three
buildings he busted his butt off to try
to you know fix everything that was
wrong there's always things that were
going wrong and if you know his whole
life depended on getting rent from these
people and you got to maintain that
building for 30 years yeah
35 years whatever you know however long
it and maybe longer mm-hmm these people
come in for for a year all right and you
know it really it's really messed up in
Chicago there's a there's a problem
where it's probably not unique to
Chicago but when people get evicted they
take like Hershey's syrup and squeeze it
all throughout the cracks of wherever
they can you can't get it out yeah it's
like a deep-clean so you got pull-up
tile for the floors and everything so
you have these people sometimes it's not
Hershey's chocolate that's true
sometimes it's even worse excrement man
yeah and and and you see what the result
is of this mentality of I get it for
free go like have you ever been a Crown
Heights Brooklyn mm yeah there's a bunch
of boarded up buildings just like yeah
you know you know what's really crazy
about New York you if you're played a
video game where there's some building
game going you know I'm talking about
like GTA for instance yeah most
buildings are just closed yeah but a few
of you can go in very little more like
division would make more sense like yeah
like some there's the things that are
open you can explore but most are
boarded up like parts of New York just
like New York it's crazy like when you
when you when I lived in Crown Heights
it's like I walk down this busy street
and I see all of these these buildings
boarded up and I'm like it's almost like
being a video game where you're not
supposed to go in the building because I
didn't design it yeah why are all these
buildings just destroyed and it's
because there's no one there to pay to
maintain it exactly and that's what
happens when you get these people who
want to invert the flow of like value
yeah it's got to start from somewhere
well there was already over the past
maybe like I guess the past ten years
people leaving cities people going out
into the smaller rural areas and getting
huge houses
for less more their mortgage would be
less than what they were paying rent
wise and they're like look at my
property like I have their gardening now
and it's like there's a lot of that
going around so how many's are emptying
out already with the internet and now
this I'm looking at West Virginia man
yeah I mean the sky link once that what
is a Skylink what's the sky link what's
it called Elon Musk even was a Starling
Starling thank you yeah that's what I
was think you know what man but not a
it's gonna be everywhere it's gonna be
everywhere that's nothing not even that
I mean there are parts of West Virginia
that have gigabit internet like a lot of
the places there hmm and so now I'm
thinking like man you could have this
massive property yeah you can run around
wherever you want do whatever you want
no one's gonna get in your way
listen you looks crazy to me about the
cities you live in New York tell me what
was the last time you talked to your
neighbor I can't not I mean I'm trying
to think you know there was one time
that I was living in the Upper East Side
where I was friends with my upstairs
neighbor but that was it I had lived in
New York for 16 years and I never knew
my neighbors never I I lived in the
building next to you mm-hmm and then
move to move to block away yeah and we
knew each other right we knew nobody
else so each other before that though
right right now I was looking for
apartment I'm like oh hey this building
opened up and you recommended it yeah
Luke I talked to us before luke
rudkowski has a video on his YouTube
channel where it's from
it's one my 2012 where he goes in the
subway and he's like look at all these
millions of people and that one of them
talks to each other let's talk to them
it's like a cool video that is cool why
bother living in the city crammed in
this tiny box for already goes on him on
a ridiculous amount of money and really
high taxes exact to be around people you
don't want to talk to well you're not
you're not thinking about what they do
after work you know you sure you see
them in the subway but they're they're
either going to work or going to the
place where they do congregate with
people you know that when you go to a
bar in the middle of nowhere there's
like five people they've go there all
the time they all know each other
there's nothing new yeah I got York you
go to a bar every single day you can go
to that same bar and you'll see no one
of the same not possible Bobby maybe
just me but I see these videos from
Corey
you know people and they're like look we
built a pillow fort in our living room
it's like yes on my property we built a
fort like a real one yeah with wood and
then we climbed up in it or we dug a
trench and like you can do so much on a
massive property you can farm you can
grow stuff you can build stuff that's
why I'm just I've been slowly moving
away from cities like what's the point
what and I mean I get it work right yeah
but now with the internet especially
with what we do yeah what's the
incentive to be anywhere near one of
these monstrosity with really high taxes
smog garbage air people you don't talk
to I mean you may have mentioned the
other day that the air is cleaner
because of this and I didn't really pay
attention to it but I was out today
skate in and I was just taking some deep
breaths and I was just like wow the air
is really cleaner I can I can tell the
difference and it was it was nice yeah
we're close to Philly but imagine way
out in the middle of nowhere West
Virginia you know I don't know I can't
name of a big city in West Virginia but
it's not New York
you know yeah it's not Chicago it's like
these big industrial places we've lived
in I'm sure there's a lot of people who
are listening who live in more rural
areas and at this point it's probably
makes more sense than ever you get a big
property with a with a low mortgage you
know tons of open space the dog can run
around and do whatever it wants you know
you got rabbits to win what rabbits do
or isn't like a city is just concrete
everywhere yeah we have turkeys over
here though they walk around rafters
well there's lots of geese here yeah yes
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you